Yves Ollech und Andree Köthe:
Die deutschen Sterneköche gelten
als Pioniere der vegetarischen Küche
und tüfteln an immer neuen Rezeptideen
für ihr Nürnberger Restaurant Essigbrätlein.
Die Gemüsesorten der Jahreszeit
bestimmen die Speisekarte.
Derzeit gibt es zum Beispiel
gedünstete Rotkohlröschen an Lauch
und mit Knoblauchcreme
gefüllte Erbsenschoten.
Seit 14 Jahren hält Küchenchef
Andree Köthe zwei Michelin-Sterne.
Pure Leidenschaft.
Ganz reduziert und einfach, einfach nur
Leidenschaft, wie ich mich ausdrücke:
Ich drücke mich übers Kochen aus.
Quasi vor der Restauranttür befindet
sich das sogenannte Knoblauchsland,
ein Gemüseanbaugebiet
nördlich von Nürnberg.
Hierhin geht Andree Köthe
jeden Tag um sechs Uhr in der Früh,
um Zutaten zu sammeln.
An 365 Tagen im Jahr.
Ich kann die Pflanzen beobachten,
wenn sie noch winzig klein sind,
aber auch wenn sie quasi verblühen.
Und dadurch habe ich so alle Reifegrade,
die man eigentlich geschmacklich
gebrauchen kann sozusagen, und
entdeck dann auch natürlich
ganz viele Sachen,
die man vielleicht so normal so nicht kennt.
Andree Köthe pflückt auf diesem Feld das,
was die Bauern wegwerfen,
zum Beispiel diese Rotkohltriebe.
Für den großen Rotkohl
interessiert er sich nicht.
Er liebt es, im vermeintlich Gewöhnlichen
das Besondere zu entdecken.
In wilden Pflanzen am Feldrand zum Beispiel.
Darunter Traubenkropf-Leimkraut:
Andere würden das als Unkraut bezeichnen,
aber für den Sternekoch ist es das
i-Tüpfelchen auf dem Salat.
Hier ist der Brokkoli bereits abgeerntet,
danach bildet das Gemüse kleine Triebe.
Genau die interessieren Andree Köthe.
Wir nehmen natürlich
am liebsten diese Stiele,
weil die haben diesen seidigen,
ganz glatten Biss, ja,
währenddessen ja die Blüten oben am
Brokkoli sich eher mit Wasser vollsaugen
und dann eigentlich
nicht so wirklich gut schmecken.
Nach der Ernte wird alles noch am
gleichen Tag im Essigbrätlein verarbeitet.
Nur frisch entfalten Gemüse und Kräuter
ihr volles Aroma auf dem Teller.
Vor mehr als 13 Jahren hat
der Spitzenkoch und Restaurantbesitzer
seine Küche auf Zutaten
aus eigener Ernte umgestellt.
Davor hatte er internationale Zulieferer,
aber die Qualität der Produkte
war nicht immer gut.
Wir haben ja früher auch aus Frankreich
Sachen geholt und … oder bringen lassen.
Und da war es dann hin und wieder mal gut,
hin und wieder mal nicht so gut,
und wir hatten einfach die Nase voll davon.
Wir haben gesagt: Okay, wir brauchen
unsere eigenen Erzeuger.
Ja, und über die Jahre,
langsam wie eine Schnecke,
haben wir uns dann
ganz regional bewegt sozusagen.
Aus den kleinen Rotkohlröschen
wird ein Gemüsegericht:
Zunächst werden die Röschen
einige Minuten in der Pfanne gegart.
Triebe, Wurzeln, Blätter und Blüten:
In seinem Restaurant kommt auf den Tisch,
was sonst meist links liegen gelassen wird.
Ja, diesen ganz jungen Rotkohl
– im Prinzip die zweiten Triebe –
die haben wir jetzt so
sieben bis acht Minuten gegart,
ein bisschen Ingweröl,
ein bisschen Butter, ein bisschen Wasser,
untendrunter Lauch und obendrauf etwas
fermentierte Himbeeren als Pulver.
Hat so ’nen ganz tollen Biss, finde ich.
Immer steht der Eigengeschmack
der Produkte im Mittelpunkt,
vom Küchenteam im Spiel mit Säure und
Aromen ausdrucksstark unterstrichen.
Spargel wird zum Beispiel mit einer Essenz
aus fermentierter Paprika
und mit Rosenblüten angerichtet.
Die Brokkoli-Stiele wurden einige Minuten
in der Pfanne gedünstet.
Auf dem Teller werden sie
mit Pistaziencreme, gehackten Erbsen
und Kräutern kombiniert.
Andree Köthe legt bei seinen Gerichten Wert
auf eine sehr feine Ausarbeitung.
Wenn man sich in diesen Beruf verliebt, ja,
dann braucht man natürlich
diesen Nervenkitzel.
Und wenn etwas Neues entsteht, dann …
dann ist das ’ne innerliche
wahnsinnige Befriedigung.
Genau diese Energie
steckt hier in jedem Gericht.
Die saisonalen Kombinationen
mit teils unbeachteten Gemüsepflanzen,
vermeintlichem Unkraut und
den speziellen Zubereitungsmethoden
machen aus diesen Speisen
kulinarische Erlebnisse.